12 02 pour une petite population d'1 3
jeux gratuits posez pas de questions
c'est parti msf double mais je sais plus
ce que ça veut dire le principe est
extrêmement simple nous sommes au
travail et en france qui est ce qu'on
fait qu'on est au travail
on travaille pas j'en suis la preuve qu
on se log et au lieu de lancer excel ou
google docs
on lance tout simplement des vidéos sur
youtube et du coup il faut il faut que
je fasse ce genre de travail et merde
j'ai vraiment fait elle table sur mon pc
si je vais sur z
anin il faut des points pour acheter la
gêne barre de fun ok d'accord l'onglet @
ça c'est mes mails c'est super chiant et
ça ça c'est longuet qui nous intéresse
on s'amuse on peut voir des choses
sensuelles
mon dieu non attends je me suis dit
direct là j'ai le droit ça j'ai droit de
regarder ça j'ai pas droit l'a lue par
exemple il faut pas user sur le site
tant qu'il est là et là en place pour
passer quelques choses sensuelles hockey
avec un écart qui arrive elle passe oui
ok on a du fun la barre le fun est à
fond on peut arrêter à ça arrive c'est
pas la même oeuvre qui repasse à temps
wen faits sont loin d'être roses et de
ne pas faire attention à moi alors tu es
en train de me surveiller aux mondiaux
on a réussi on a gagné 124 euros on a
travaillé quatre arrêts on a eu du fun
pendant quatre heures
c'est un très bon ratio deuxième jour du
coup avec l'argent je peux faire quoi je
peux m'acheter un abonnement sur le site
pornographique deuxième jour pma ça
changeait ses cousins accorde donc je
suis censé faire une vache sur photoshop
pendant ce deuxième jour voilà je suis
graphiste hop là on retourne sur le site
de vidéos incroyables
oh mon dieu oh mon dieu sait si sensuel
c'est fauché sur photoshop chum hpc elle
est fâchée mais qu'ils ont changé ils
ont viré l'autre parce qu'elle a pas
réussi à me griller en plein emploi en
pleine en place a pu parler à aa
les mecs avec ses bouteilles de lait
qu'est attendue vient de passer et
repasse n'importe quoi quatre heures 4h
nier et troisième jours est-ce qu'on
peut acheter des choses avec notre
argent shades of lovers mondiaux qu'est
ce que c'est que ça ah mon dieu ça se
fouette le boul
oh mon dieu c'est incroyable ce qu'on
est en train de voir c'est exceptionnel
attend plus cela comme si à regarder
n'importe quelle vidéo un peu hot les
rires câble rk - mec se faire fouetter
en tenue de catwoman un lation de voix
faire ça non seulement été licencié mais
en plus tu deviens la risée de toute ta
vie
oh mon dieu on a fait cinq heures deux
fois trois heures de taff on est de plus
en plus fort quoi end of alfano c'est la
fin de l'alfa de nsfw howe
d'accord je suis déçu
non non sur astro creep on va jouer un
petit parisien qui va devoir exploser la
gueule d'astronautes en mission voilà
objectif utilise la souris pour cliquer
autour de la zone est guidé la lienne à
travers les chambres ton but et
d'évoluer pour créer un nid est infecté
la station spatiale toute entière ok
donc là il ya déjà eu un canard
ok on sort de là à ça c'est comme de
reims club d'aurélien c'est le même boya
où il est un peu plus ridicule on a eu
une grosse limace yeux alors où je peux
aller je saute sur l'alhambra mon dieu
ça brûle il faut que j'étais
l'interrupteur du coup je viens sur la
lampe hockey au monde où l'on veuille
sauté dessus
on va lui sauter dessus ben là dans le
cou beach hockey
enfin davis et ça c'est sûr of hop hop
hop on se casse par là on va aller à
gauche à droite jugent stress jusqu'à ce
que ou fin quelques tuyaux dont elle
avait trop de choix faut arrêter les
conneries moment je fais du meilleur
attend mario all bat dessus là bas il ya
un truc à tourner voilà c'est juste un
truc à aucun sa sortie demandez pas
comment j'ai fait j'ai rien compris
juste pas mais les cliques mec je veux
un festin gala les oui oh oui le
meilleur boulbon à l'accord atteint ok
je paye dans les chiottes jamais procès
normal de croiser analia n'y a pas de
problème ouais ok je suis passé et la
mecque je peux la fausseté part oui
j'ai évolué et je peux maintenant speed
and most blob j'ai pas compris au oui je
peux marcher avec c'est trop bien mais
on parle tu es le gars qui nous avaient
écrasé regarder le plat à d'accord c'est
ça j'en vois un dard venimeux allait tu
choisi une forme hassidique l'évolution
acide ou alors la télékinétiques évolué
je ne peux pas faire ça non je peux
vomir un liquide très corrosif et
l'autre c'est la télékinésie je peux
faire bouger les trucs et conseils dans
je préfère le truc bien hardcore
réception et bemba à la casse que
j'avais volé au deuxième gars que j'ai
tué allez on passe là-dedans avec celui
qui n'avance à tour oui mais j'ai bien
fait de prendre sa chance avec j'aime
bien ça dégage allègrement à n'importe
quoi tu ne fais pas moins peur tu ne
fais pas plus humain assez a faim c'est
matic
et l'affluence couloir avant 6 heures
plus tard
oui oui oui eh ben voilà
sirgant voulait changer de vie et
devenir un alien vous savez comment vous
y prendre c'est nul ça on est maintenant
sur scouts scout un jeu dans lequel on
va faire deux scouts
allez c'est parti on va voir si on à
faire une photo pour rien ou pas il faut
pas toucher mais max est impossible de
ne pas toucher le messie super chouette
de faire un bon score à attend mais il
ya forcément une touche sais pas combien
temps omeyyades
je vais détruire le cul attentes autant
mais le premier l'a fait 46 secondes
mais c'est pas possible je suis vraiment
en train de trahir ce jeu où tu passes
le bsr ok ok ok avec on se croirait ou
mais c'est quoi ça j'ai déjà roulé sur
des feuilles ça jamais fait ça le
parcours faut bien apprendre la rame en
avant deux mais n'en est rien ok on est
chaud on est choqué si tu vas faire
beach yolo à mais c'est une question de
style aussi apparemment tombée cers
comme permis moto si t'as pas de
styliste ne donne pas je dis que de la
merde entre les deux lots bien sûr fait
qu'on se prenne le [ __ ] de truc en
béton là on y va à la on connaît la fois
les vides
moi je voulais le voir des visages
virage on a fait une minute cette pierre
soir à temps les mecs on voit carrément
battre le meilleur faut surtout pas
partie comme une fusée pas se laisser
aller
ok on y va oh là là oh là là haut la
mecque où je croyais pas je vous en fais
la promesse hop hop hop la d re ligne
droite
non non combien 54 on prend son temps on
pense pas juste moi qui donne les
conseils mais je suis première pas
respecté youtube se voter quoi aller
c'est une blague ses blagues c'est
pourquoi on peut plus rien
non j'ai perdu là on se concentre c'est
parti
beaucoup de temps
mais c'est ce à quoi c'est ça et que
damas n'est qu'après mais ce qui vient
de se passer et voilages anciens
principes de petites vidéos sur ces
trois jeux gratuits je voulais a été
chargé les liens sur la description
n'hésitez pas et ne sait pas aimer les
jo ça vous a plu
c'est magnifique vous voyez on a try
hard on a recommencé à recommencer
encore et encore quitté être saoul et
mais au moins on arrivait promis on a
gagné 5 et pour toujours se surpasser ou
tricher pour gagner à lathus deux
prochaines personnes regardent et portez
vous bien un job du monde